salut c'est Hugo cette semaine dans la
grande histoire je voulais vous partager
un documentaire un peu particulier
puisqu'il n'a pas été réalisé par une
journaliste mais par une espionne flore
Rebière est une ancienne agente des
services secrets français mais
aujourd'hui elle a tout quitté pour
raconter son histoire dans ce film elle
nous dévoile les mystères du métier
d'agent secret en allant à la rencontre
de trois espionnes étrangères comme par
exemple Yelena une ancienne espionne
russe qui a fait partie d'un programme
d'infiltration aux États-Unis
[Musique]
mon travail c'est surveiller tout ce qui
se passe dans le monde 24 24 jours sur
c'est pas la prère fois qu' VI V
qu'
elle s'approche d'une auto bleu elle
dépose son sac
[Musique]
DEAS et vous pensez sérieusement que le
métier d'espion ressemble à
ça
je m'appelle flore j'étais agent des
renseignements français pendant 10
ans le monde de l'espionnage pour moi il
était pas totalement inconnu dans le
sens où mon grand-père était
espion même si lui n'en a pas dit
grandchose il était très
[Musique]
secret l'image que la société a des des
femmes espionnes ce canton souvent parce
qu'on voit dans les films des super
héroïnes qui tirent dans tous les sens
qui se bataillent qui boivent des
cocktails dans des tenues sexy pour
séduire la cible à
corrompre c'est pas ton cas non je n'ai
pas fait tout
ça je suis rentrée en école de police à
ans j'avais atterri aux surveillance des
gardés à vue donc c'était pas le truc le
plus passionnant de la terre faut quand
même le dire donc j'ai vu un appel
d'offre j'ai décidé de postuler comme on
postulerait à n'importe quel job
finalement j'ai été recruté pour faire
de la filature parce que ils avaient
besoin de femmes notamment parce que
c'est un univers où il y a pas beaucoup
de de femmes et du coup ça manque pour
pouvoir être crédible dans une filature
on peut former des couples ou une bande
de copines ou je sais pas se fondre dans
une masse pour pouvoir observer ce qu'il
y a
autour j'ai fait certaines missions qui
peuvent être proches de certains films
il y en a dont je ne peux pas
parler moi j'ai travaillé donc à
l'époque des attentats Charlie Hebdo le
13 novembre le 14 juillet et c'est vrai
que ça a été une grosse pression et puis
des images qu'on voit défiler sur
l'ordinateur en boucle de de violence ou
de vraiment
anxiogène on se retrouve vraiment
catapulté dans un quotidien qui qui peut
être difficile à vivre sur le long TER
et dont on peut pas parler à
l'extérieur moi j'ai été espion pendant
10 ans et je me suis toujours demandé
comment les autres espiones vivent ce
métier qui est si différent des autres
alors j'ai décidé de partir à la
rencontre de TR
d'entre trois femmes qui ont servi dans
trois pays différents et dont les
histoires m'ont particulièrement
[Musique]
touché la Russie ça représente une
véritable culture du renseignement et
j'ai voulu voir Elena parce que c'est le
cliché de l'espion russe c'est ce que
l'on appelle un agent
[Musique]
orment mais prendre en filature un
ex-agent du KGB c'est pas une mince à
faire je t'ai eu hein tu m'as bien eu
j'ai pas pensé que tu étais monté à
l'échelle dis donc ah non pas du
tout je m'appelle
ov aujourd'hui je dis ça ouvertement
j'étais un agent secret russe
[Applaudissements]
soviétique je suis dans une V de la SIBE
qui s'a
tomon j'ai vécu pendant l'Union
soviétique c'était aussi la période de
la guerre froide
[Musique]
vraiment on pensait que les États-Unis
c'est le pays de capitalisme on exploite
des travailleurs tandis que chez nous
c'était les travailleurs qui recevit
beaucoup plus de
privilèg à l'université quand j'étais
étudiante on m'a proposé de rencontrer
quelqu'un qui est venu de Moscou il
pensait que je suis un bon candidat pour
le travail à l'étranger en tant que
agent secret
[Musique]
voilà my name is Annie Mason and I was a
former intelligence officer for the
British security service MI5 way back in
the
1990s all right I can do
this bravo great teamwork
you my dream job is I wanted to be a
diplomat traveling the world you know
living in the embassies and all that
sort of
thing so basically if you get a Classics
degree from Cambridge it's like a a fast
ticket into the heart of the British
establishment i had a well of a time at
the University and graduated when I was
still only 20 and then applied to the
Foreign Office and had a very mysterious
letter from the Ministry of Defense
saying there may be other jobs you find
more interesting pleaseing this
[Musique]
number oh fuck it's
MI5 how are you how are you so nice to
meet you in me h of oh my good that's h
very nice to you yeah
OK
so my name is
hil i worked at thesesas for 16 years
I've only known work in national
security i was born in
[Musique]
Ethiopia when I was only four years old
there was a civil war and uh my family
had to leave and we decided to SLE
Egypt there were challenges to not being
Egyptian and living in Egypt and so my
family felt well we need a place to call
our
own my father chose
Canada so I speak Harari which is an
Ethiopian dialect and I speak Arabic as
well as French that I learned in in que
yeah
four
[Musique]
languages my professor approached me and
said um h you speak so many languages
you would be um an incredible asset to
the
[Musique]
organization
we had a huge television set my
colleagues and I were standing and
everyone had their hands on their faces
like
this knowing that I will be in a place
where be central to the
response
dans tous les services de renseignement
du monde avant d'être recruté un agent
fait l'objet d'une enquête approfondie
moi par exemple on m'a posé des
questions sur ma sexualité on m'a
demandé de donner les noms de mes amis
on m'a demandé mes opinions politiques
mes appartenances religieuses et an n'a
pas échappé à cette
règle officer to my family
home she looked like a little old
grandmother you know short and glasses
and short grey hair and everything and
she started asking me intensely personal
questions about my sex
life ok I'm 21 and I have to talk about
whether or not I've ever had lesbian
experiences or something like that and
she said le sign this document and I
looked down and it was a notification of
the terms of the official secrets Act
as soon as you sign the official secret
Act you told you can't tell anyone well
obviously my father guessed because I'd
spoken to him before I even approached
them so I told him but even so I was
only allowed to tell my partner at the
time and my best friend if I trusted
them which I did my parents knew my
friends did not my brother was super
excited and I remember him say
et je pouvais pas M dire à ma mère que
je suis partie pour m'entraîner voilà de
devenir un agent secret les parents
pensaient qu'on travailler comme les
interreprètes après un an d'épreuv et
d'interrogatoire Elena UDA et Annie
intègr les services secrets mais une
fois entré ces trois espionnes n'imagine
pas les risques qu'elles vont
[Musique]
t'encir à 19 ans en pleine Guerre Froide
elena est recrutée par le KGB pour faire
partie d'un des programmes les plus
secrets au monde le programme des
illégaux un réseau d'agents spécial
ement entraîné pour s'infiltrer en
territoire
[Musique]
ennemu vous êtes arrivé à 20 ans et donc
entré très jeune pour cette formation
moi aussi en fait je suis rentrée très
jeune dans dans la police à 19 ans oui
j'ai fait euh 5 ans d'investigation
avant de rentrer dans les services
français comment vous vous sentiez toute
jeune comme ça est-ce que vous sentiez
prête pour notamment la mission que vous
apprêtiez à faire je pourrais pas
imaginer qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
d'être un agent sous une couverture
travail à
l'étranger c'était aussi un peu de
fierté de faire quelque chose que
pas pas tout le monde peut pas tout le
monde peut faire
voilà
[Musique]
en 87 elena est envoyée avec son mari
André sur le continent
[Applaudissements]
américain bon alors deux espions mariés
envoyés ensemble en mission moi j'avais
jamais
[Musique]
vu Elena et André vont jouer au couple
occidental modèle et pour ça ils vont
emprunter l'identité de deux citoyens
canadiens
décédés au début de notre émission moi
et mon mari on était déjà pas Elena and
on était
Tracy et
Donald Tracy c'était c'était quelque
chose que vraiment je pensais oh c'est
pas jolie quoi mais j'avais pas le
[Musique]
choix
ce qu'il me fallait
faire disons premier temps il fallait
bien s'installer trouver un apportement
chercher peut-être quelques cours pour
apprendre en métier juste me donner la
possibilité de trouver le travail parce
que ce qui nécessaire de de gagner de
l'argent avec la langue c'était
difficile bien sûr au début comme il n'y
avait pas d'internet à l'époque on
pouvait juste voir ça sur place ou
acheter un
dictionnaire
d'argot euh aussi fallait se comporter
plus à la manière occidentale fallait
apprendre à sourire à être optimiste
comme les américains être plus sûr de
nous ce qui n'était pas facile parce que
les Russes ils sont pas sûrs de soimême
de de leurmême
quoi donc on a regardé pas mal de
[Musique]
télévision fallait vraiment choisir
quelqu'un et essayer d'imiter cette
cette personne j'adorais par exemple
Catherine Deuve estimezvous représenter
une image de marque de marque la mienne
qu'est-ce que vous avez volé à Catherine
de je pense un peu le comportement quand
on se sent comme ça libre
disons sûr d'elle et puis bon d'élégance
aussi parce que en étant une femme je
voulais rester la femme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi les enfants servent
bien en tant que couverture n'est-ce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas personne ne va soupçonner euh la
famille avec des
enfants Elena et André cach le véritable
identité à leurs enfants j'avoue moi
quand j'ai appris ça ça m'a choqué je
suis pas sû que j'aurais pu faire
ça comment on se sent dans ce CASL par
c'est pas confortable de devoir mentir à
ses enfants comme ça capable de le
transmettre le truc de votre payso pas
notre but nous mission et notre mission
c'était la chose la plus importante dans
notre vie on a on s'est engagé on a on a
dit on était les les soldats je dirais
Elena et André jouent à la famille
modèle mais ils ne perdent pas de vue
leur mission s'approcher au plus près
des cercles du pouvoir
américain mon mari a commencé faire des
études dans dans
l'université univity c'était vraiment
très important c'est vraiment une place
où on pouvait trouver des gens
intéressant et des gens qui peut-être
même influencer la politique
américaine la communication avec le KGB
était pour la plupart par la radio les
messages cryptés on a bien sûr appris
écrire des lettres avec l'encre
invisible passer quelques chose en
passant à côté de
quelqu'un puis les dernières années on
utilisit l'ordinateur pour envoyer
quelques messages
cryptés à vrai dire on avait pas peur
d'être démasqué parce que on savait bien
si on fait pas des erreurs et c'est pas
possible de trouver un illégal parmi les
milliers dans un
pays
[Musique]
en 2010 un agent double du KGB transmet
à la CIA la liste de tous les illégaux
présents sur le sol
américain le jour de notre arrestation
c'était le jour de l'anniversaire de mon
fils il fêtait ses 20 ans et euh tout
d'un coup à notre maison venit des
agents de FBI en disant que il doivent
nous
[Musique]
arrêter pour les enfants c'était le choc
parce que il comprenit pas ce qui s'est
passé il pouvait pas croire ses
yeux j'ai compris que si me trouve
coupable je risque d'être emprisonné
pour 25 ans c'était vraiment dur à
accepter
comprendre après de semaines passées en
prison Elena et André reçoivent la
visite d'un diplomate russe ils leur
annonce qu'ils vont être libérés et
échangés contre des espions américains
une première depuis 20 ans et la fin de
la guerre froide deux avions un Russe et
un américain au bout d'une piste de
l'aéroport de vien Autriche espions
rchang en quelques minutes contre espion
[Musique]
américain deetour
Russie tout
àurn que le histoire de famille est
unnmesonge de ce qu'on a fait notre
travail a permis de plonger dans
d'autres cultures de voir vraiment pas
mal de choses de connaître le monde je
dirais on a vécu le rêve
américain en quittant Elena je me
demande comment l'ancienne espionne a
réussi à retrouver sa propre identité
après 25 ans passer dans la peau d'une
[Musique]
autre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lorsque j'étais dans les services
français j'ai eu accès à de nombreuses
informations classées confidentiell et
ces secrets sont parfois lourds à
[Musique]
porter an l'agent du MI n'a pas pu
garder le
silence deler labre des servic Britan
unecision qui va faire
passerpion
no no we could because everyone all
villages would have seen US driving
around so I had a thing and I bought
these huge sunglasses and then painted
with very dark nailnish on the inside
three times so you could not see out of
them he had to wear them all the way on
the
drive
l'armée républicaine irlandaise a
revendiqué TR attentats en 3
[Musique]
joursand est affecté au contreterrorisme
les indépendantistes de l'IRA veulent
prendre le contrôle de l'Irlande du Nord
et ce livre a une série d'attentat
sangl
some
[Musique]
ofondon trying to track and stop those
sort of operations that is prely what I'
signed up to do and got some very good
results which I can't talk
about au sein du service de
contreterrorisme an fait la rencontre de
David son futur compagnon
[Musique]
2 ans après leur rencontre David tombe
sur des documents compromettants
révélant des écoutes illégale et un
projet d'assassinat du colonel Kaddafi
directement commandité par les services
britanniques Kaddafi s'imagine en
prophète arabe mais c'est un régime de
terreur qu'il impose au 6 millions de
libiens avec l'argent du pétrole il
finance le terrorisme international ses
services commanditent l'attentat contre
un Boeing de la Paname en Écosse 270
morts in Libya in an illegal operation
to try and assassinate a foreign head of
state which went wrong and killed
innocent
people David raised all this he took it
right up to senior management saying you
know got concerns about this but um yeah
everyone was just told to just follow
orders and shut up usual
thing so um at that point we decided the
only option was to go public and go to
the newspapers and try and create a bit
of a scandal which would then force the
government of the day to reform both the
work of the Spies to improve it so they
could better protect our fellow
[Musique]
citizens Mr allegations have raised
serious questions about just how MI5 has
run6 plot to kill the Lian leader colel
gadfi
if we had stayed in the UK we would have
immediately been arrested by the secret
police and immediately held on remand in
um British prisons separately Scotland
Yard is investigating whether a former
MI5 agent breached the official secrets
act so when the story eventually broke I
was running around London trying to sort
out the travel trying to sort out uh
some money so we get packing and sorting
out the flat without looking too obvious
that we might be about to fly
[Musique]
i booked the L it felt like the last
flight out of London and I remember
saying to Davis the um wheels left the
tarmac it we're out
[Musique]
few so is that it this is the house this
one safe house where we h out for here I
pictureently i don't know and so how did
you end up here we went literally on the
run around Europe for a month we
traveled to the Netherlands um down
through Paris down to the far southwest
of France by on ok then Barcelona it's
sort of weird backpacking holiday with
MI5 chasing us very closely is it
open it's open
[Applaudissements]
so I was really the one who planned
where we go and how we get there well I
knew how I would Hunt me so there are
often moments when I'd be saying right
we've been here two days we have to go
now come out of the hotel you know and
that's it and he said no calm down come
now of course we couldn't use uh ATMs to
extract money from banks so we had to
carry cash everywhere because they could
be tracked even then sometimes you
disguise yourself
this is why trem look with blir if
thenwh
[Musique]
Beig après 3 ans de Caval le couple
décide de rentrer en Angleterre pour
faire reconnaître leur statut de lanceur
d'alerte
[Musique]
David va alors assumer seul la
responsabilité de la fuite d'information
confidentielle
é
[Musique]
condamnation
David revealed malpractice crime and
incompetence on the part of the
intelligence services and he did it in
the public interest he still believes
that he was right to do so that's why
some months ago we appealed to the
European European Court of Human Rights
and of course you know just being very
sad as well at what had happened to Dave
and after all those months of living in
hiding together being together all the
time pretty much suddenly to be on my
own um was quite a difficult adjustment
as well
David sera condamné à 6 mois de prison
et le couple se séparera en 2006 après
avoir traversé toute cette
aventure
[Musique]
être traqué suspecté par ses propres
services c'est peut-être la pire chose
qu'il puisse vous arriver qu
controrisme ça peut paraître incroyable
et pourtant c'est arrivé à HUD MB une
espionne canadienne que je suis allé
rencontrer à
[Musique]
Londes
[Applaudissements]
que cet individu qui serait lié au
groupe terroriste Al-Qaïda aurait obtenu
un visa pour séjourner au
Canada you know I felt privileged to
have been selected the excitement of
every manager when they saw uh my name
and identified me somebody who spoke
Arabic was like we're going to have on
on our desk it was really an emotional
time uh feeling that you are entering
this world that is so special and and
but you still don't know very much
about so my ro an officer was to Lage
signaltellig
[Musique]
2 ans après le 11 septembre le Canada
connaî une montée de l'islamophobie
depuis le début de l'année mosqué ont
été vandalis et de
r
monéal un phénomène qui touche le
service de hudda et qui l'affecte
personnellement à cette époque la jeune
femme ne porte pas le voile au
[Musique]
travail and my parents are you know very
devout and very very peaceful very like
just amazing and at work it was you know
very conservative very
hostile workplace uh this equating
religious uh identities with uh with
extremism was something that really
bothered me more and more as time
went so I felt that it was um you know
really
for me to wear the
hijab very nice
colors so I decided to wear it over the
weekend and I thought you know this is
this is going to happen today and I wore
it I drove to
work and
then something in me said don't like
it's it's going be a big
deal
you know like exactly what I thought
would happen happen like the security
guard stoppped
me you know every morning I say good
morning and they know me so I was like
it's me I just decided to wear this
they're like ok you know get back get in
but I
underestimated um just how negatively it
would be perceived by senior
managers
my supervisors were like oh like we
didn't know that you're going to be
wearing a hijab and how can you be an
officer and wear a hijab and will you
now not shake the hands uh of men and so
you know and I was like no no I'm it's
still me I'm not different I'll shake
people's hands like you know this is
just something that I feel really
important to me and then certain source
files that I was working on that I was
[Musique]
quelques jours après elle reçoit une
convocation de l'Inspection générale des
service et l'un des responsables lui
demande de passer devant le détecteur de
[Musique]
mensonge and so if your body is nervous
and when the stakes are this high
there's no way that you're going to have
a real um a real result that you could
really um make sense of and then somehow
this could mean something right I I
felt I felt I was going to be stripped
of my clearance that I would be walked
out and my hands were
shaking and I I had not told anyone my
parents
UD refuse de se soumettre au détecteur
de mensonge après 10h d'interrogatoire
rien ne lui sera
reproché mais la jeune femme sera mise
au placard pour le restant de sa
carrière l'espion canadienne va
finalement décider de porter plainte
avec de sesègues pour
harment discmination to
environ are things that I and this
government find absolutely unacceptable
and I can also assure you that the new
director of C find that to be
unacceptable so he is talking about your
case
right so how did you feel to see that on
the news like at this level it's huge
right yeah there was finally an admion
by the organation that you know our
workplaces were not what they're
supposed to be and and and I did that so
I feel really proud
and yeah I
really it's been so incredible mee mee
you um I know when I thean
um you many friends behind and you leave
people who understand what the
profession is like so it's it's it's
just refreshing it's amazing to be
talking to another woman about it it's
incredible to see how we can have so
much in common even though we are like
you know oceans apart and working at
different times because you were working
like few years before I was in in the
service and so
[Musique]
j'ai rencontré trois femmes qui comme
moi ont choisi de retrouver leur liberté
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que l'on a pu
se confier dans ce film et partager avec
vous un peu de nos vies
[Musique]
despion
voilà j'espère que ce documentaire vous
a plu un grand merci à Flore Rebière et
liicia M5 qui ont réalisé ce
documentaire et à toutes les équipes de
brut qui ont participé à sa fabrication
n'hésitez pas à commenter mettre un like
et à vous abonner pour ne rien rater de
nos prochaines vidéos et moi je vous dis
à la semaine prochaine pour un autre
épisode de la grande histoire